[Music]  of course I care about you very deeply  that's why I want to see you with a good  guy you discovered Colin you supported  him through the entire editing process  and the minute he got successful he  didn't have time for you that is until  he need you again I was married to a guy  like that and you deserve better you  deserve someone who treasures you who  who opens doors who walks on the outside  of a sidewalk right what kind of old  lady lace-curtain handbook is that out  of huh  Liza stop pretending to have a clue  about how I think or Who I am you know  nothing you don't even know what a meme  is yes I do Lauren just sent me one  that's not a mean it has meme fun how is  that not just is it living what the hell  is of you may you just know it  [Music]  you